I'm back from Maui if you hear that
that's just that calm that's inside of
me hey I'm back from that Maui why we
here oh hell yeah boy somebody just
somebody you heard it somebody won that
log somebody got the fire all themselves
Mahalo Aloha
konichiwa Mahalo
Madagascar I'm back I'm that back of
Lantern baby put that candle in me cuz
I'm lit let's get into it
yeah I'm back I'm back from Maui all had
a good time look if you don't know if
you're you know maybe 40 percent sure of
something if you're going to heaven
because I think most people are if
they're really honest with themselves
they come in at probably about 40% you
know so if you're about 40 percent sure
that you're going to heaven then you
could go to Maui and now he's like I
mean it's there are times I close my
eyes and I said damn man if people this
place is gonna give heaven a run for its
money it just I mean it's romantic you
could be by yourself and it feels
romantic
dude I felt like everything every time
the breeze came by was trying to just
you know just trying to get me back to
its room it was just that kind of just
that kind of spirit it was just
something you know and the water will
come you'll be laying there taking a nap
and you think you slept you're laying
far enough from the water and about you
know maybe eighteen or thirty you know
thirty or sixty fifty kind of forty
minutes later that water will start
licking at your [ __ ] feet you say day
what's up buck buck buck oh so it's you
know everything there is China you get
home you have some of the beach will be
in your pants some sand like what is it
who is it what is it you're like I hope
this is you know some female saying I
don't want no you know male sand trying
to get in my pants but
you take your pants off in st. a bunch
of sandal jump out of your pants he said
well damn so just mother nature that's
where she really goes to just get on
I mean Maui just wants to love you and
it really just wants to love you and and
and I stay I noticed after a bit that
the the ocean will start doing your hair
for you yeah it do it I had at one point
I had like a little thing algae right
above one of my ears you know you got a
little conch over there on the left it's
like you know I look like kind of like
you got like a little seahorse kind of
just hanging off that backsplash I mean
it's I look like you know shunk like you
know like a consequence you know just
out there we're just just the what the
ocean and everything will do your hair
for you but I had a wonderful time and I
had so if you haven't been to Maui I
totally recommend it and they say
there's different islands and I want to
go back there and do a a show soon and I
want to go to some of the different
islands over there and the people just
people a lot of people I did think this
I felt like there could be even though
it's very wonderful it definitely seems
like a place where some people that
might have done a crime would go to hide
it's got that kind of cry me Heidi sort
of vibe you know
but what else oh I feel like so I want
to tell you more about Maui I'll
probably wait to get back into the
studio I guess where do I went there oh
let me tell you this you go to Mama's
fish house and they got it's in Maui and
it's nice you get there you're like aw
it's too nice you know it's real it's
kind of it looks fancy mate Diouf right
when I got there I thought to myself I
want to steal something I'm gonna go
that's how nice it was that's my initial
reaction but instead who sit down relax
even if you're by yourself get you a
little non-alcoholic beer you feel me
get a um one of the crab cakes I got the
crab cake that's it get one crab cake
unbutton your pants welcome to Palestine
Sun [ __ ] is fundamentally good it was it
was definite one of the best meals ever
had and I was by myself too and um yeah
when I'm by myself at a restaurant I
start to you almost start to freak out a
little because you start wondering if
people think you're like in witness
protection or if you're you know people
kind of look at you like you maybe your
spouse just passed away or something
they give you that you know they maybe
give you a little extra bread or
something half an extra little you know
baked uh you know little little
croissant piece or something because
they think maybe your wife's gone she
you know they thinks are you know you
they think maybe you don't know what
you're doing with your life if it is
interesting if you go to a restaurant by
yourself people kind of look at you like
oh maybe he you know you know maybe he's
still trying to do skateboarding or
something but but he's too old for it oh
one of the things that got me at the
restaurant was the guy trying to upsell
me on our soup look don't don't I don't
need it don't the guy you know he's like
oh they got omegas in the soup dude I
don't give a damn if Voltron lives in
that [ __ ] dude I don't care if I want
the soup I'm getting the soup you know
he said it's got a rare carrot base what
the hell is that buddy
that's nothing dude I don't care bro no
care if you open my mouth and just drag
me through mr. McGregor's garden if I
want vegetables I want vegetables just
don't upsell me on it
you know he's tell me he tell me oh we
sprinkled the top of it with secrets
[ __ ] don't care if I want the soup I'll
get the soup
you know I just I don't like being up
sold with trickery words you know of
this you know the the the haricot vert
was blessed by um a cleft palate wizard
I don't give a dang but do not upsell me
with the BS just give me the facts what
is it is it soup and if I wanted I'll
get it
did you enjoy that clip well you really
would have enjoyed it if he was watching
on a TCL TV TCL is America's fastest
growing TV brand it's so fast it's the
Carl Lewis of television brands it's
that Florence Griffith visual jointer
it's celebrating its 5th anniversary
from launching in the US markets I have
one of these at home and these suckers
are just I mean it's like having a Mona
Lisa on your wall that plays everything
you want follow TCL at TCL underscore
USA on Twitter and Instagram for more
details for more information about TCL
visit TCL usa.com
that's TCL usa.com